[Music]
could you
offer some sample language or tell a
story either one is fine could be
hypothetical or just provide some
language for getting
curious because there's uh
there's a spectrum of options to choose
from some of which might be passive
aggressive some might be aggressive
aggressive and
with the understanding that you're not
invalidating your conclusion you're just
hitting suspend on voicing that
conviction that you have of being right
and getting curious what might it sound
like to to get curious
yeah
so one of the things that we work on
in our negotiation course
at harvard is um
separating empathy
and assertion
and being high on both in any given
conversation
so you both want to be
high empathy
and curious and
you want to have skilled and clear
assertion like here's how i see it let
me see if i can explain it in a way that
is clear even to myself
as i pull apart why i see it the way i
do
the mistake that we make and this is i
think a little bit of what you're
alluding to is that sometimes we
conflate those two so i'll think to
myself i know i'm supposed to ask a
question so i'll phrase this as a
question
why would you think that
which
which isn't really a question why would
you think that is like that's the
dumbest thing i've ever heard
with a question mark at the end
so
and so what happens is we ask
quote unquote questions that are really
disguised assertions thinly disguised
assertions and you're much better off
just saying gosh that seems crazy but
but what do you see that tells you that
that's true and just naming that i
actually don't agree or i can't imagine
that
pulls apart the assertion and just says
it clearly and then i can ask a genuine
question which is
but gosh i mean most the time you're a
pretty smart guy so why would you like
help me understand that
and then my curiosity becomes more
pure more clean actually and so passive
aggressiveness is actually
unspoken feelings frustrations or
assertions
that then leak through
us pretending to be curious
so if everyone's
reasonably dysregulated let's just
imagine
just imagine a world let's just imagine
a world in which you know this this calm
surface that we all maintain at all
times
sometimes falters and
uh two people are getting heated maybe
it's the second or third time that
they've had the same
disagreement or argument
what can someone say to
sort of down regulate
that and get to
curiosity and you already gave perhaps a
few examples but
any other thoughts on how to language
that
um my guess is that you're familiar with
the research by john gottman up in
seattle
and i have some familiarity yeah please
provide a
an overview yeah well an overview just a
connection to to the question that you
just asked
so he invites married couples into his
lab and he invites them to talk about an
issue that's stressful between them to
have a difficult conversation
essentially hooks them up to heart
monitors and videotapes and all of that
and then you know he says that he can
watch for five minutes and predict with
their different numbers based on his
different studies but
90 ish 90 92 percent accuracy whether
they'll divorce within three or five
years
so
part of the reason i name this is that
for me it really says it's not just that
we have difficult conversations in our
most important relationships
those conversations are the relationship
that if we find a way to have them
productively or
constructively
then the relationship will thrive
whether it's a personal or professional
relationship
and or
is where we start to disengage because
you just don't get it you won't listen
and the relationship starts to fray
so what gottman is listening for are
what are the indicators right that he's
listening for that tell him which
direction it's going to go and one of
them
is
that as a
conversation gets heated and starts to
escalate
one of the spouses
will
often make a joke
but the purpose of the joke is that it's
a invitation to step outside this
argument and to see it for what it is to
see what's happening which is that this
is the conversation we usually happen we
usually have and how it usually goes
and so often it's a little bit of an
inside joke but humor
by the way i listened to your
conversation with anne lamott who i
absolutely adore
she's a treasure she is a treasure um
and what does she call laughter is
carbonated
holiness holiness yeah so laughter also
in the brain just
gives us a little bit of instant
perspective that we suddenly see the
absurdity of our own behavior in many
cases and so it's an invitation to just
name what's happening it's like a meta
move
so for instance with my
husband who also teaches negotiation by
the way so
love to be a fly on the wall for some of
those
yeah you can imagine so we fight about
how we fight like yeah like we usually
have this is like my friend's kids my
friends are therapists and their kids
are like stop therapizing me exactly
exactly exactly so we're like yeah
you're not listening
oh a little most difficult conversations
yeah yeah so that's the fight we have
stopped putting your batman in my face
that's right
that's best alternative to negotiated
agreement folks since inside joke yes
yeah exactly that was very nice inside
baseball joke
yeah waving your bat around in a
romantic relationship is not usually a
successful strategy you know there are a
lot of people who would find me very
appealing
but but one of the jokes that he and i
make
when we have the wherewithal to do it is
like why will you not just admit
i am good and you are bad that is what
this is about right it's about who needs
to apologize whose fault this is etc so
as things escalate your ability to just
name that underlying dynamic sometimes
makes the other person laugh right and
you can step out of it for a moment
and then that gives you the opportunity
to say look
obviously we've had this conversation
several times
i'm not understanding why fill in the
blank i'm not understanding why what i'm
suggesting doesn't make sense help me
under like genuinely help me understand
that
or
i'm not understanding what
you're most worried about here
that often
helps
and it needs to be a genuine ask you
can't say like what are you worried
about
because that's really
a hot question it's like you shouldn't
be worried about anything so why are you
being so stupid as to be worrying about
something
as long as you can
step outside
see oh i'm not being curious right now
and i don't have to pretend
that i agree to do it i think that's
really
the key and i don't have to say
there's no truth right but
from where i sit i can only see some of
the pieces of the puzzle
you have the other pieces of the puzzle
and we don't really putting those pieces
on the table for discussion is is how we
figure out what we have to work with and
then at the end of the day we still
might not agree about this but it might
open up new options for how we handle it
you